[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens on
parler sport l'émission à ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux du sport local
même si la saison sportive touche à sa
fin nos chroniqueurs ne sont pas encore
en vacances ils vont vous donner le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes pendant une heure
quatre spécialistes sont autour de cette
table
présentation en musique on commence face
à ma droite c'est le pilier de cartes
amateurs ils étaient là lors de la
première saison il ya trois ans il est
toujours là pour nous éclairer sur
l'actualité sportive yann dujarrier be
stars dans la catégorie et master son
club de belize îles 78 est avec nous
aujourd'hui elle compte aller vous très
très bien en bonne forme au trésor nous
vous avoir une nouvelle fois sur ce
plateau
après une séance au vélodrome tout va
bien tout va bien on passe à ma gauche
un musical est de retour du pérou elle
est aussi sublime qu'intelligente à nous
surprend à chaque émission avec ses
analyses techniques de haut niveau notre
ambassadrice de charme et l'aide de la
grange professeur de pole dance à
versailles et avec nouvelle fois sur ce
plateau
je suis ravi d'être ici quand allez-vous
d'accueillir encore à merveille
vous êtes de retour du pérou près
fraîchement de retour de vacances
bon j'espère vous êtes attaque pour
cette émission que vous avez récupéré le
décalage horaire
oui on va dire oui repasse de l'autre
côté à musique il est de niveau ligue
des champions il vit football et respire
football
il rêve football sur nos informations
didier deschamps l'aurait appelée
secrètement pour composer sa liste des
23 pour la coupe du monde
georges gomis président dit ce porte le
plaisir sporting club est avec nous
aujourd'hui centaline celui qu'elle
jouera tous récemment
écoutez c'est sympa mais j'espère que
c'est leur demeure ou pas dit deschamps
et vous appelez à environ vers paris si
t'as pas besoin de mon avis je pense
qu'il est assez grand pour prendre ses
choix et j'espère qu'il prendra les bons
choix et kangoo qu'on soit champion du
monde c'est tout ce qu'on lui demande ça
nous fera ce sera l'occasion de faire
une belle fête
or espèrent tous on termine à ma gauche
ainsi qu'un autre georges est avec nous
sur ce plateau l'huile sa spécialité
c'est le football américain
il a été un président de l'un des plus
grands clubs de foot us de france les
templiers à del en cours aujourd'hui
il a pris un peu de recul mais il suit
toujours avec attention les résultats de
son ancien club
georges agostino est avec nous pendant
une heure bonjour michael george comment
allez-vous ça va vous avez pris un peu
de recul mais vous continuez à 70 il est
en cours je suis tous les matchs des
catégories de jeunes aux vieux de n'y a
pas de problème moi je suis toujours
licenciée
vous êtes toujours c'est le match de
tous les temps pas de problème alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de golf et de l'avenue du
numéro un mondiale justin à tomasz sur
les greens du saint quentin en yvelines
le 28 juillet prochain sur l'open de
france nous évoquerons également un
sujet hamiti qui est tabou dans le monde
du sport la sorcellerie
nos chroniqueurs ont certainement leur
avis sur la question nous avons
développé ces thèmes on ouvre une page
football américain on commence donc par
du football américain pour leur dixième
et dernier match de la saison régulière
de deuxième division les templiers
d'elancourt ont été inspirés ce samedi
12 mai à domicile ont ils l'ont emporté
19 à 6 contre les diables rouges de
villepinte le score 19 à 6 donc cette
sixième victoire de la saison permet aux
élans pour toi d'accéder aux playoffs de
fin de saison on écoute la réaction par
téléphone du nouveau président des
templiers à joël da silva façon c'était
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés déjà
depuis le début de saison c'était aux
minimes 1 l'accession aux play-offs pour
ensuite je vous dis la finale de
conférence nord donc on est carrément
dans le plan de route qu'on s'était fixé
en début de saison pour nous c'est
mérité malgré une saison qui qui a
relevé quelques os est certes un petit
bas pour se serait bien passé c'est une
notion perdre totalement grecque
ils affronteront en demi finale de
conférence les corsaires d'evry pour
continuer à croire à une montée en fin
de saison la question sur ce thème les
templiers peuvent-ils déjà être
satisfaits de leur saison à ce niveau là
la compétition oui oui oui à un petit
nom pour georges gomis
enfin petite ville entre vous et hélène
et échanges à les hellènes commencer
aux lettres du côté de jean georges à
l'étranger
allez-y je ne porte jamais
habituellement mais cette politesse
réalisé gère la politesse vais traverser
la courtoisie sépare donc j'ai commencé
les mois je pense que peuvent être
satisfaits de leur première partie et
alors là il rentre dans une autre phase
et j'ai leur objectif premier je pense
pas que ce soit ça soit seulement de
participer aux play offs ça serait
plutôt de d'accéder à la division
supérieure et être satisfait là
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est aux
play-offs je pense que c'est un de leurs
premiers objectifs mais leur objectif
prioritaire ce serait peut-être de
remonter et pour le club et pour les
yeux pour pour les sponsors et pour pour
le futur et je pense que là on peut pas
s'avancer en disant vrai on va monter
directement mais leur objectif caché je
pense que c'est de me remonter en
première division c'est bien mais ils
peuvent encore mieux faire si je
comprends bien on peut dire que
ils n'ont pas fini leur saison ils ont
fait une première partie de saison qui
était très bonne
voilà il arriva au point final mais ils
font les play-offs et les play-offs
c'est comme la finale finale si on y va
c'est pour aller au bout et je pense que
ces gars là ils se hisseront play-offs
et où ils vont mordre dans la pomme et
essayer de remonter donc elle-même pour
vous c'est satisfaisant
en tout cas ils atteignent l'objectif
qu'ils s'étaient fixé
c'était sûrement déjà un peu compliqué
pour eux évidemment que l'on doit pas
s'arrêter là si il ya d'autres choses à
avoir derrière mais si c'était cet
objectif là qu'il s'était mis des gens
en premier objectif est qu'ils l'ont
atteint c'est déjà une première
satisfaction on peut pas dire qu'on
n'est pas satisfait d'un temps de ceux
des objectifs qu'on s'est fixés
quoi qu'il arrive et ils ont quand même
un bilan de 6 victoires 1 nul et 2
défaites et c'est déjà honorable après
voilà si la saison
on a encore quelques matches on verra
sur les matches qui vont suivre s'ils
peuvent dépasser ça et on leur souhaite
je donnais à part la haye and juste
avant de vous donner la parole george
agostino vous qui êtes le spécialiste
yann qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
et bien comme comme hélène c'est vrai
que l'objectif en début de saison
puisque président nous l'a expliqué
c'était d'accéder aux playoffs je pense
que le reste ne sera que du plus s'ils
arrivent à détruire
voilà du plus du bonus maintenant voilà
donc la saison pour moi elle est déjà
satisfaisante pour eux puisqu'ils ont
atteint leur objectif
le reste le reste en mieux maintenant on
sait on l'a toujours dit ici une montée
ça se prépare une montée ça se fait pas
n'importe comment
si c'est pour faire le yoyo remonter et
redescendre aucun intérêt donc
donc il faut être sûr que quand on quand
il si le monde et puisse rester plus
rester en première division
ils ont été très très longtemps en
première division
et la descente était
il ya deux saisons maintenant c'est ça
c'est vrai il ya deux ans c'est
certainement déjà le bon moment pour
remonter parce que faut pas non plus
rester trop trop longtemps en 2e div
mais voilà faut que ce soit préparée
anticipé et ne pas ne pas brûler des
étapes
donc s'ils le font tant mieux en
espérant qu'ils aient déjà prévu le
prévu la suite
gendrey postino alors j'ai un scoop
scoop on arrive et vous invite on a reçu
un communiqué de la fédération il ya à
peine une heure comme quoi le
championnat élite à être modifié bon ça
fait une dizaine d'années que il y avait
une élite très très restreinte donc
difficultés à rester en élite parce
qu'il y avait que huit clubs en france
83 sud
il est très restreinte donc là ils
viennent de changer la donne ça fait on
a fait une bonne dizaine d'années quand
se bataillent pour ça et là sa prothèse
ses fruits on va passer de huit à douze
clubs sis dont une hors sis dans le sud
ce qui fait avant il y avait on était
ados match de la montée y avait les demi
finales puisque on est qualifié pour les
demi-finales nord est avec le finaliste
lors qui monte directement en première
division et il y avait le dernier 2
de l'élite nord dont les visions qui
descendait la personne descend de
l'élite et on a deux qui montent donc
c'est les deux demi finalistes au nord
et les deux demi-finalistes sud qui
montent donc on va passer l'équipe de 8
à 12 et là je vous dis c'est une
bataille déjà une bonne dizaine d'années
tous les clubs parce que il ya huit très
bon club en france enfin le voit dire
5,6 c'était trop dur de s'accrocher pour
les nouveaux qui monte et c'est donc on
va dire entre guillemets les plus
mauvais reste et de l'élite
on aura à peu près la moitié des clubs
qui seront jouables on va dire que
quelques clubs français sont
difficilement jouable donc être publiés
aujourd'hui santa un match de montée en
élite
avant on était à deux matchs de monter
en élite donc il faut que dans cette
très bonne nouvelle pour l'instant dont
une dizaine d'années evry les vrais
fauves à thé brick qui sont qui sont
invaincus en d2 qui sont invaincus donc
une très bonne équipe dans son jeu
et voilà comme les spartiates d'amiens
notamment les spartiates wake était
dangereux news qui vous ont battu deux
fois également donné son avis au début
de saison ce serait une équipe qui
serait qui serait à battre amiens ce
serait avec lui ça se jouerait la montée
donc là sinon que non ce pâté à kamien
pour être premier de la poule pour se
revoir les demies il était resté raffin
comme dans chaque période
donc la voilà la donne a changé il ya à
peu près une heure et on est donc à un
match il ya un match primordial cédant
pas ce week-end là le doute celle
d'après ce que j'ai dit c'est bon alors
est ce que c'est le bon moment
il est vrai quand on est descendu il y
avait cité un effet générationnel il ya
beaucoup d'anciens qu'on veut maintenant
on en élite reste est resté restait donc
on a intégré nos mondes jeunes l'année
dernière pour la première année était
compliquée parce qu'on n'a pas atteint
les play-offs
cette année ça va beaucoup mieux que
jean rue des craintes si on était
rentrés dans l'élite
ancien format à 8 là on aurait été
vraiment compliqué la forma à 12 ça nous
donne un peu plus en sont un peu plus
léger et ce quelque chose que je pense
que tout club là où à reprendre
possession fall mois le président est un
président va prendre possession de
l'information et quelque chose à faire
quoi ça leur donne vraiment le buste
pour y arriver pour pour tout donner
surtout sur un lac jean n'a pas leur
donner trop de pression c'est compliqué
de faire des vrais une équipe invaincue
oui c'est chez eux chez eux
c'est exactement comment ducom jeu comme
je le disais tout à l'heure c'est une
première partie de saison réussie et
pour les laits pour ivry c'est la même
chose ils ont réussi leurs proches là
c'est les play-offs c'est quelque chose
d'autre
c'est une deuxième phase qui s'ouvre est
là bas il y a on referme une page on
ouvre une autre et donc c'est sur un
match décisif il faut il va pas falloir
se louper donc quelle pression ou pas va
falloir que les coaches et les joueurs
soient au rendez vous et j'espère que
la préparation doit être bonne et ce
jour là ils auront tous les ingrédients
pour pouvoir faire un gros match et les
monter parce que c'est quand même un
club connu les templiers est bon ce
serait je serais content que pour il
encourt pour pour les amoureux du q
comment période américains dans la dans
le département et dans la dans la région
enfin région de proche en proche
limitrophes tu puisse venir regarder
votre choix
pourtant pli voilà la question sur cette
thématique est ce que les templiers
d'elancourt peuvent se satisfaire de ne
pas monter cette année là nigeria il
faut pouvoir il faut voir les régler
ensuite est-ce qu'avec la nouvelle
première division à 12 clubs y aura
qu'une seule descente où il y aura deux
descentes il y aura eu de l'essence a
augmenté hier est une descente une
montée donc ça veut dire que c'est
l'opportunité l'opportunité à cette
année parce que la quitte ou double
c'est à quitte ou double c'est juste que
ce sera un peu plus compliqué pour
monter parce qu'il y en a plus qu'une
place alors que là il ya deux places et
ils pourront jouer la finale beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus relâché sera quoi ça
va rien parce que c'est toujours
intéressant d'être d'être champion de
jack lang ligue 2 et mettre une ligne 2
ligne bâle 2 mai mais là c'est vrai
qu'il ya une vraie véritable opportunité
c'est ce serait dommage de pas là de pas
la saisir d'accord actuellement je suis
d'accord parce que du coup
je file y en a bien expliqué les choses
c'est l'ouverture à deux classes et ça
se produit qu'une fois c'est maintenant
après
simon pas cette année on attend
fermement qui montre l'année prochaine
parce qu'ils lancent faire de
l'expérience là mais c'est maintenant
que le créneau le fun
cela se fait la porte en plus cette
saison apprend on l'a juste avant
maintenant c'est vrai c'est le moment
idéal que c'est une opportunité
phénoménal ou simple fait de vous le
fait de ne pas reporter les choses donc
là c'est une opportunité mais bon tu
arrêtes pas joué le jeu à fond la temps
était 3e là tu peux pas tu peux pas
monter donc quand une occasion les
saisons se suivent et se ressemblent pas
donc à partir du moment où vous êtes la
plus comme le président l'a signifié
tout à l'heure ils ont une équipe
rajeunie
donc c'est encore l'opportunité si
jamais il saisit cette opportunité là
derrière ils ont de quoi faire
[Musique]
ouais je finis là dessus c'est que nos
u19 sont au final choplin de france on
aime nationnale et j'ose ce week-end il
ya de la relève l'arrêt tard les voilà
les coins pour cent de chance pour voir
les templiers en d1 la saison prochaine
selon vous georges rigaud sinon je vous
dis là c'est quoi le prochain match
cinquante après le football américain
poursuit ceux ci ont parlé sport part du
handball plaisir n'y arrive plus en
nationale 3 dominé une grande partie du
match les isérois ont concédé leur
troisième défaite en quatre matches de
championnat contre l'entente plessé 1 à
domicile ce dimanche 13 mai
le score est sévère 33 à 24 on écoute
les réactions à la sortie du match que
ce genre de match voilà faut vraiment
être à 200 % si on veut l'emporter
voilà un moindre relâchement et on prend
en trois quatre buts d'écart et un
deuxième relâchement et voilà on termine
à moins 9
mais bon l'essai de mérite amplement
cette victoire est une bonne équipe qui
a un fond de jeu cohérent donc je
m'attendais à un match difficile mais
après on s'attend jamais à à perdre 2e
une grande partie de la saison les
plaisirs oies se retrouve désormais à 4e
de national 3 derrière marolles et leurs
adversaires du jour l'entente pcn
plaisir est tout de même en embuscade à
un petit point de ces deux équipes
la question sur ce thème l'équipe de
plaisir est elle en train de gâcher sa
saison oui ou non je vous rappelle
qu'ils sont promus quand même dans cette
division ont fait un petit duel entre
vous georges et yann alors il ya de vous
pensez comme voilà ils sont promus mais
il avait fait un très très beau début de
saison ils ont pas été
épargné par les blessures donc c'est
vrai que ça ça joue un peu sa joue
certainement sur le sage ou sur le
collectif et ça vous sur le sur le
groupe donc donc c'est dommage parce que
ben c'est le sprint c'est bien d'être
régulier sur la saison est de marquer
des points mais ça joue souvent sur les
sur les derniers sur les matches et là
ils sont en train de en train de rater
le raté le coche
maintenant voilà oui ils sont promus ils
vont ils vont prendre de l'expérience et
la montée double montée sur deux années
ça c'est quand même très très dangereux
donc c'est peut-être un mal pour un bien
par là point là pour la suite de leur du
club et pour la suite de leur de leur
équipe faut voilà ils sont capables ils
ont ils ont eu les opportunités ils ont
saisi ça va demander à certains moments
là ils ont une mauvaise non parce que là
ils vont quand même terminer dans le
haut du tableau 2 dans le haut du
tableau de nationale 3 c'est déjà très
bien pour une pour une équipe promue
jeudi qu'ils cachent pas leur saison
aussi donc non duel contre georges
agostino ya les deux jeunes gens pètent
c'est pour ça serait prête à confusion
le destine aux effectivement j'aime
hiver parce que cette élection de saison
malgré tout quand on monte le temps de
faire connaissance de de ce championnat
qui est devant moi je trouve cette
saison même si ça craque un peu sur la
fin même si ce n'est pas terminé pour
moi ça reste très positif pour eux et la
double montée c'est vrai dans n'importe
quel sport c'est toujours très dangereux
puisque on se croit arrivé et puis ça
tombe vite là ils ont fait une bonne
saison ou finir 4e au pire je pense qu'à
très fier deuxième encore une pas finir
2e donc c'est tout à fait convenable
pour une première saison en d3 il aurait
mois le jura mal justement contre saint
sébastien le septième du championnat
chaville et hersin coupigny et deux
derniers donc ses joies et puis je sais
pas si leur objectif était de ne pas
descendre en moins sous la couette matin
donc c'est complètement atteint mais
c'est vrai que c'est dommage de pas
concrétisé d'avoir mais dû à des
blessures dues à des éléments qui sont
ils ont marqué un convoi finalement la
physionomie du championnat
est-ce qu'il ya pas un petit un petit
regret de se dire finalement on aurait
pu finir premier ou deuxième
le 4 mars dernier notamment il avait
remporté une victoire super importante
contre saint paul saint polois inquiéter
leader donc il aurait pu finir premier
finalement oui mais toute façon vous
avez les capacités en interne est promu
et qu'on jouait le haut du tableau déjà
c'est qu'on a de la qualité
et puis deux étant donné qu'ils ont des
blessés que derrière cela il ya comment
ils sont qu'à quelques points du premier
avec un calendrier que je dirais
favorable puisque il rencontre des mal
classés des mal classés bon après ce que
est ce que commandant leur dans leurs
prévisions il avait il à la monter
financièrement est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir l'assumer je ne sais pas mais ce
qui est important c'est qu'ils peuvent
jouer encore les les premiers rôles et
terminer dans les dents le haut du
tableau dans les deux premiers
éventuellement deuxième au pire des cas
troisième on perd des gains pardon là je
pense que non non il faut qu'il faut
qu'ils jouent leur chance justement sans
pression il faut qu'ils jouent leur
dernier match avec avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé avec beaucoup de ferveur
et puis a essayé de débat et de faire de
faire de doubler tout le monde sur la
ligne droite était blessé ou pas je
pense que si l'on si l'on joue sans
pression justement la mise il joue sans
pression ils doivent jouer sans pression
s'ils jouent sans pression et qu' il y
croit vivre à fond si la chance leur
sourit ben ils passeront devant tout le
monde et je serais content pour
justement les blessés on va y venir tout
de suite on écoute les réactions par
rapport au nombre de blessés importants
d'un effectif en ce moment on écoute la
réaction mais c'est sûr que cette année
on a un un effectif qui fait que si on
perd un ou deux joueurs
sur des postes clés voilà on a un
déficit sur le point de vue défensif ou
les dispositifs qu'on aligne sont pas
les dispositifs pour n'aligne
habituellement c'est pas les joueurs
qu'on a aligné comme habituellement donc
forcément on essaye de trouver des
solutions là où finalement on n'a
peut-être pas et voilà mais bon c'est
juste parce qu'on essaye de rester
compétiteurs jusqu'au bout et de se
battre avec nos armes dujarrier
finalement c'est logique on peut le dire
cette fin de saison elle a comme but de
nous l'expliquer avec des blessures aux
postes clés ça veut dire qu'ils sont
obligés d'aller chercher dans les
remplaçants des tutelles titularisé et
donc bien on ne descend d'un niveau de
jeu on descend un poil le niveau de jeu
du groupe et donc les remplaçants qui
remplace les remplaçantes et exxon
devenue titulaire
ce sont des garçons qui sont à plaindre
des divisions inférieures et compromis
qu'ont à qui on donne de l'expérience
donc voilà par contre ils vont
certainement se servir de ça pour avoir
une expérience qui va qui va grossir et
faire un mur et un groupe qui peut qui
peut vous donner une bonne surprise
c'est dans la prochaine et préparer la
saison prochaine
cette saison
ont le temps de se remettre voilà d'ici
la saison prochaine donc on va assister
à finalement comment dire une montée
d'expérience et puis finalement les
expérimentés vont venir font peu de la
tentation d'en ouais on vient ton année
prochaine n'est pas l'émission perd
aussi juste que les blessures dans un
sport collectif ça fait partie du trio
de choses qu'on doit qu on doit
anticiper on sait que thomas tiquement
il y aura des blessures
il faut produire plus en plus généraux
restent rançon ça se peut
malheureusement je connais pas
effectivement le
l'effectif mais voilà je viens de monter
déjà il faut le temps de s'adapter
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure est-ce
que ça va peut-être encore plus envie de
l'aimer finalement cette équipe par
rapport à son parcours quand on voit le
nombre de blessés la saison un petit peu
héroïque qui sont en train de oui
surtout ils ont montré ce qu'il pouvait
faire
finir deuxième déjà en mieux il
finissait 2e sait déjà
oui c'est déjà pour les supporters qui
doivent avoir bien sûr c'est un heureux
événement déjà de monter de 4e division
comme ça être promu est tous là haut
c'est oui effectivement c'est un très
beau parcours
après cette large base résultats nous
allons passer à la seconde partie de
l'émission n'ouvre notre coup de
projecteur du golfe dans notre coup de
projecteur belle surprise pour le à
chênée open de france c'est officiel le
nouveau numéro un mondial est très
médiatique justin thomas ce soir au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
28 juin au 1er juillet pour participer
au rolex séries
celui que l'on surnomme hajiti est un
poids lourds du circuit américain le
sportif a notamment remporté 7 titres
depuis octobre 2016 il a également été
l'un des piliers de l'équipe américaine
vainqueur de la ryder cup en 2016 on
écoute sa réaction au micro de
l'european tour
je me réjouis d'avoir la chance de
participer à un tournoi de l'european
tour
je n'ai plus eu l'occasion de le faire
depuis mes débuts en tant que
professionnel lorsque j'ai participé au
dunhill links championship
je ne sais pas trop à quoi m'attendre
puisque je n'ai jamais joué ici ce sera
mon premier rolex séries
je sais qu'ils sont relativement nouveau
sur le circuit européen ce sera très
sympa d'y participer
une venue à bénéfique pour le rendez
vous français qui fêtera cette année sa
102e édition d'après le président de la
fédération française de golf
jean-charles le numéro un mondial
présent à l'open de france donne encore
plus de crédibilité si besoin était à
l'épreuve
joystiq thomass et ses amis pourraient
donc qu'être présent et donner un éclat
tout particulier pour c
l'édition 2018 et vous pensez qu'il est
venu en vue de la ryder cup qui se
déroulera justement sur le parcours de
l'albatros ici à 50 onu alors justin
thomas sera forte à faire pour ce
rendez-vous il doit s'employer face au
vainqueur de l'an passé à tommy
fleetwood et l'espagnol john rame numéro
4 mondial et deux joueurs ont confirmé
leur présence la question sur ce thème
l'open de france est il déjà une
réussite vu le casting
oui oui on est unanime vous êtes tous
unanimes sur la question genre agostino
peu de monde oui oui après le verdict
pour vous voilà d'après le plateau
effectivement avant le numéro mondial se
sont pas trop ça y est c'est comme c'est
écrit quelque part ils attendent 30
portion de plus de public
donc effectivement numéro un égal succès
égal à visibilité égal
voilà oui c'est donc ça est ce que vous
êtes c'est un succès
donc oui quand on a les meilleurs sur un
plateau c'est toujours déjà c'est un
gage de réussite puisque les essais le
plateau réunir tout le monde
le meur enfin un évident dans un
événement c'est déjà de compliquer avec
les blessures avec tout ce qui se passe
là à pouvoir réunir tout le monde ici
avant la ryder cup même pour prendre les
repères
niveau au niveau du golfe et pouvoir
pouvoir
comment s'imprégner du par à la fin du
parcours de des hôtels et tout ce qui
s'ensuit je pense que oui oui c'est une
réussite pour moi c'est c'est
extraordinaire même de pouvoir
alors moi peut-être tué peut-être
prendre ma place voilà j'ai géré cette
année vouloir cependant 2016 en tout cas
rory mcilroy
l'irlandais étaient venus sur l'open de
france le golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines avait vu sa fréquentation
booster de 30%
juste pour un joueur et ce n'était pas
numéro 1 mondial il était numéro trois à
l'époque donc yann finalement en termes
de billetterie en tout cas je suis relax
comme pourrait demander à un
organisateur comme comme roland garros
même s'ils n'ont pas besoin d'eux mais
le jour où rafael nadal dit qui vient
pas à roland garros les bills et les
billets pour la finale seront un petit
peu plus long à être à être ça va être
un peu plus de temps pour pouvoir les
vendre parce qu'on sait très bien que
quand on classe quand on m'a à la finale
de roland garros et on a 80 % de chances
de voir de voir nadal 22 95% de chances
de voir nadal jouer là bas voilà on sait
qu'ils sont lassés les numéros un
mondiaux ce n'est qu'un tournoi européen
du de valeurs européennes donc ça veut
dire que et voilà la leaf et ryder cup
jousson
joue son effet effet ryder cup est
également 7 millions de dollars aussi à
la clé on pourra les faits ryder cup
gestion parler d'argent dans le golfe
s'est pas passé un sujet en tout cas
c'est en effet l'un des les plus
rémunérateurs du cirque du soleil bien
sûr les membres le l'argent n'est pas à
n'est pas n'est pas un atout dans le
golfe s'est pas c'est pas pour ça qu'on
joue au golf
bien sûr mais donc voilà l'effet ryder
cup a son importance puisque comme vous
et georges ba oui les gars viennent pour
prendre leurs repères pour la ryder cup
qui sera sans fin mais qui sera
l'événement l'événement de numéro un
pour eux cette année quoi parce que
gagner la ryder cup c'est c1
c'est un ca marqué dans une carrière
comme s'ils ont gagné un grand chelem
un autre moment dans la saison quoi donc
c'est normal qu'ils c'est normal qu'il
soit là et c'est super pour pour les
pour les spectateurs mais c'est vous
qu'on me dise et par rapport au tennis
et non là on est on allé tête de série
quoi les meilleurs les meilleurs qui se
déplace et va le meilleur en ce moment
c'est de cet hommage à la semaine
dernière à la lumiére warcq et hip hop
qui est pas très âgée qui est qui est en
devenir déjà il a tiré du monde là
aujourd'hui il est le premier il est le
premier et je pense que bombe a essayé
encore ça georges misse plus de sponsors
il ya des sponsors après ces îles comme
on dit c'est le personnage
moi je le connais pas c'est à face je ne
m'intéresse pas suffisamment gueule pour
connaître sa personnalité maintenant si
c'est ainsi sien comment un joueur type
régulier réguliers qui qui n'a pas de
panache qui n'a pas de panache qui prend
pas de risque bon bah c'est sûr que les
sponsors et ce qu'ils aiment n'ont cessé
type tiger woods s'est etc au tiger
woods ce qui ne sera pas présent à temps
qu'il ya des il ya déjà lancé voilà
après si il aura sa personnalité il aura
peut-être aussi des annonceurs qui vont
qui vont miser sur sa personnalité et je
pense que les annonceurs ce qui ce qui
les intéresse c'est la personnalité du
joueur même qu'ils soient talentueux ou
pas s'il a une bonne paire 100
personnalités y misé dessus alors s'il
est encore plus les scellés il a une
super personnalité et du charisme et du
talent bah tout le monde à dos quand je
vois bien que c'est que les
organisateurs ils ont un gros coup à
jouer sur sur 7 sur cet événement parce
que l'enchaînement d'avoir
un numéro bouddha qui vient sur
l'organisation du européenne
trois mois avant la raideur voilà la
ryder cup derrière si l'organisation
pour les joueurs se passe bien et que
les dix que le tournoi se passe bien sûr
sur les trois jours et pour la promotion
les gars voudront certainement revenir
par la suite
et là il ya quelque chose à ne pas rater
et à anticiper sur les années qui
viennent parce que là où justement
financièrement ils peuvent continuer à
surfer sur une vague sur une vague
positive voilà et tout ça c'est une
anticipation pour passes ratées et ne
pas rater cette année qui est vraiment
importante pour information de les
planètes les planètes sont donnés le
livre il ya aussi quelque chose de très
important c'est qu'ils n'ont pas annoncé
encore tout plateau est ce qu'on pensait
que la venue de justin tu auras peut
inciter ses copains comme jordan spitz
les stars américaines à venir mais je
pense qu'à partir du moment où on a les
meilleurs ceux enfin les meilleurs arias
et voilà les autres vont vous commencé
un peu à regarder vous dira finalement
voir ce qu'ils sont pas décidées vont
peut-être finalement se décider je sais
pas après comment se passe la sélection
mais c'est aussi une occasion de se
mesurer l'occasion d'aller tâter le
terrain comme on a comme on en a parlé
oui ça peut décider alors on parle
beaucoup des américains sur ce plateau
depuis tout à l'heure
meyer égard il y aura également les
meilleurs français michaël lorenzo-vera
troisième l'année dernière sera de
retour sur l'albatros grégory bourdy
quadruple vainqueur sur le circuit
européen sera également de la partie
romain wattel raphaël jacquelin grégory
havret ont également confirmé leur venue
mais celui qui va susciter beaucoup
d'espoir pour une victoire finale le
dimanche ce sera alexander levy le
numéro un français sera bien sur les
greens saint quentinois en juin prochain
c'est positif aussi de voir des français
de haut niveau venir s'inscrire sur ce
projet en ile de france
comment disait on a quand même hâte on
sera trois mois des raiders cup pour
l'instant j'ai ouï dire qu'ils ont aucun
français de cette équipe européenne
donc c'est une des dernières occasions
de se montrer et éventuellement gagner
une des places acier acier si on croit
possible
alors le mieux placé avec sandler les
biens qui pourraient aller dans les
quais bus aujourd'hui la main sur ce
week end là il va avoir une grosse il a
remporté notamment à ce que c'est au
maroc s'il fait une tribune les ventes
et les papiers d'une prestation sur le
parcours ça peut lui ouvrir la porte
pour la ryder cup donc là il a à lui il
faut pas qu'il sera maintenant après bon
il restera trois mois à travailler
derrière ou parce que c'est bien de
gagner une sélection quand on est un peu
border mais derrière il faut assurer le
jour 2
le jour du jour du jour j ça permettra
de voir aussitôt masse bjorn enfin
alexandre lévy sur le parcours sur le
parcours de l'albatros parcours
forcément qui est piégeux on peut dire
alors ce bémol par contre il manquera
deux figures marketing importante pour
ce rendez vous on disait tout à l'heure
n'y aura pas tiger woods il n'y aura pas
également le français à victor dubuisson
deux figures finalement marketing victor
dubuisson plutôt pour la france plutôt
qu'à l'international hors jeu gomis ça
peut jouer aussi sur cet open de france
nous savons pense finalement la laddh au
ludoval non je pense que la venue des
meilleurs déjà ses voix victor dubuisson
ce qui prime victor dubuisson et en
français sur le bruit en plus ce sens
oui plutôt victor dubuisson je pense là
ils auraient importé du monde aussi si
par sa personnalité
tiger tiger woods ont laissé sur la faim
il est sur la fin et on s'est mis en
route et sur la fin c'est un peu comme
angers de retour il qu il recommence
alors il revient bien il va réserver
revient de blessure il sera - regul il
sera moins réguliers pour elle assurait
la prochaine ryder cup pourrait en tout
cas il sera vice capitaine quoi qu'il
arrive
mais bon toute façon les absents des sa
c6 est déjà fin c'est des gens
spectaculaire et les absents basse et de
ne pas être à la fête
c'est dommage c'est donc en golf
deux spectacles devant yann il ya quand
même une importance dans le golfe c'est
qu' il n'y a pas qu'un seul tournoi qui
a organisé en même temps donc allé
prendre du positif en gagnant un autre
tournoi parce que le numéro un mondial
n'est pas là ça peut aussi avoir son
importance pour le psychologique du
joueur donc si tiger gagne un tournoi où
fait une bonne prestation sur un tournoi
annexe aux états unis ou ailleurs c'est
pas non plus c'est pas non plus négatif
et puis toute façon il ya d'autres il ya
d'autres joueurs qui jouent aussi
ailleurs on peut pas non plus être en
forme toute une saison et il faut
sectorisé ses objectifs on continue
maintenant parler de golf dans notre
focus du jour l'open de france de golf
qui se déroulera sur le même parcours
que la ryder cup 2018 on le disait
précédemment on commence d'ailleurs à y
voir un peu plus clair sur l'encadrement
de l'équipe européenne à moins de deux
moins de quelques mois de l'événement
alors qu'on pensait voir un vice
capitaine français sur les greens du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines en septembre prochain
le danois thomas bjorn va finalement
nommé deux tricolores comme assistant
leur nom raphaël jacquelin et grégory
havret deux quarantenaires du circuit
européen qui dispute chaque année on l'a
dit précédemment également l'open de
france de golf mais qui n'ont aucune
expérience en ryder cup sur les greens
et deux français auront notamment pour
mission de faire le lien entre les
membres du staff le public et la presse
il pourrait également accompagné des
joueurs sur le parcours la question sur
ce thème
avez vous le sentiment que cette
nomination de la part de la team europe
est un lot de consolation
oui ou non
ça c'est un peu ça mais non enfin petit
duel entre les deux georges encore le
retour à l'ailé non mais bon c'est sûr
que ça se passe en france est bon on
pourrait penser mais il faut pas il faut
pas comment il faut pas non plus jeter
mon chien ce qu'ils ont réalisé ces gens
là ces gens là qui sont ces
professionnels ils ont ils ont comment
ils ont quand même de la valeur et sont
sur le circuit européen depuis une
quinzaine vingtaine d'années bahinchi
oui oui donc l'horizon ils ont quand
même du crédit et je pense pas que l'on
puisse nommer des gens comme ça parce
que les choses se passeront dans leur
pays je pense que au delà au delà de la
au delà de ça c'est des professionnels
ils ont une longévité dans dans le golfe
et si on prend des gens c'est parce qu'
on en croit e et on va pas participer à
la ryder cup pour y participer on y va
on y va parce qu'on y est on y croit
parce qu on a des objectifs et on en
sélectionne les meilleurs c'est pas un
cadeau
non c'est pas un cadeau non c'est on
peut en sport il ya pas de cadeau on va
toujours chercher on a toujours ce qu'on
mérite
et il ya des gens qui n'y seraient pas
là il y en a certains qui dirait mais
c'est dommage parce que c'est ces gens
compétents et là ils sont là ils sont
français certes mais ils sont là donc on
respecte leur leur travail lors leur
force leur cv leur parcours est bon
c'est pas des fois on n'a pas de grandes
références peut-être professionnels sur
des victoires
pezens mais ça n'empêche qu'on peut être
de une personne de qualité dans le
domaine dans lequel on travaille
josé mourinho avant d'être josé mourinho
il est en 3e division
le cours de consolation pour georges
gomis pour vous il par contre pour moi
oui même si on parle pas tout à fait de
sport peu connu dans les coulisses du
sport en gros c'est sera des attachés de
presse plus ou moins plus ou moins pour
la presse française le public français
entre guillemets ils ont
voilà le brésil et notamment le public a
relaté le clown des locaux dégâts c'est
connu je pense pour
les gens qui suivent ce sport oui
c'était la moindre des choses et ça sera
encore vraiment le gros lot de
consolation parce que si l'axé douala
qui sont dans le staff de cette très
backup voilà y'a pas de raison prendre
un français parce que juste ça se passe
ça tu as enfants on savait que si on
prend on prend dans la joie et au délire
pression médiatique aussi de la part des
défenses et peut-être pour avoir des
mandats qu'elle doit rentrer dans
l'encadrement moi je pense que ils
peuvent quand même apporter parce que
ils peuvent apporter puisque ceux qui
connaissent le terrain très très bien
maintenant c'est une équipe européenne
je pense que si ça avait été des joueurs
français qui était sur le circuit
américain pendant treize années et enfin
de plusieurs années et qui est que la
ryder cup se déroule en france là il y
aurait un intérêt puisque des joueurs
européens viennent sur le territoire
américain
là c'est les joueurs les joueurs
européens beaucoup connaissent déjà le
golf national
donc on n'a pas beaucoup de y'a pas
grand chose à leurs données en
informations quand on est un local sur
le sur le terrain donc la voie là ils
vont essayer d'organiser d'organiser
l'ambiance autour des joueurs pour pour
pour faire monter la sauce parce qu'on
sait que c'est important dans la ryder
cup le public le public a son rôle à
jouer mais là il devait y avoir
normalement un vice-capitaine dans cette
équipe équipes européennes on en avait
parlé il y avait notamment les rumeurs
victor dubuisson genre monde velde
thomas levet ils ont tous les trois a
connu la ryder cup
finalement on va peut-être pu les
prendre dans l'encadrement plutôt que
raphaël jacquelin grégory havret qui
sont des bons golfeurs qui ont gagné
quelques titres qui n'ont pas été en
ryder cup n'ont pas d'expérience de
ryder cup
peut-être que les personnes n'était pas
complètement disponible ou je ne sais
pas sur quelle
sur quoi exactement il ya forcément
plusieurs critères voilà pour pour faire
le choix de prendre plutôt un tel qu'un
tel et c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu
attendre des jours un peu plus connu
après sur quoi ça c'est sûr que ça c'est
décidé les infos il ya la partie comme
en individuel et puis à une partie qu
est ce que c'est les personnes qui qui
qui ont une plus de qualités
individuelles dans la gestion d'un riser
que pousser c'est une notion d'équipé
est ce que ces personnes là sont
efficaces par rapport à comment une vie
de groupe à un partage en groupe à une
compétition en groupe c'est pas assez
s'est pas dit il ya certaines personnes
individuelles si c'est individuel oui
ils sont là ils arrivent ils arrivent à
s'impliquer parce qu'ils ont une
personnalité et quand c'est en groupe
ils ont tellement de personnalités que
ça peut nuire aux autres on aura la
réponse en tout cas dans les prochains
mois du 28 au 30 septembre sur les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
on continue notre focus du jour par du
cyclisme sur piste ya dujarrier la
pépite tricolore mathis deux groupes
tout juste 18 ans ne s'entraîne pas ces
dernières semaines au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la raison
elle est partie depuis quelques semaines
au japon
on voit d'ailleurs les images à l'écran
son objectif s'améliorer sur l'épreuve
de keirin avec des professeurs
spécialisés dans cette discipline
elle reviendra dans quelques mois petite
information c'est son choix et elle est
partie seule la question sur ce thème
fait-elle le bon choix oui oui vous êtes
une question yann oui mais qu'il
connaissait bien mathématiques
aujourd'hui elle a pas
la pas faire ses preuves à titre
individuel sterk on sait qu'elle a des
capacités hors normes qu'elle est
capable de beaucoup beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui mathis qu'elle a besoin
c'est elle a besoin de courir elle a
besoin de prendre de l'expérience et en
allant japon est là elle a complètement
raison
surtout que le keirin doit correspondre
en plus à ses qualités de d'explosivité
de sprint long donc donc ça ça colle
vraiment
et je pense que l as well as bien fait
d'y aller on a vu dans les années
précédentes ce que ça pouvait donner
avec avec françois pervis qui allait
aussi de sa propre initiative elle qui
partait il partait seul seul au japon en
pèlerinage pendant pendant près de payer
près de trois mois et ça lui a permis de
devenir deux fois champion du monde
écrit voilà tout à fait donc mathilde
aujourd'hui elle va gagner prendre
énormément d'expérience là on l'a vu
elle a pas appris à faire du vélo a
appris à monter un vélo parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'il ya une très grosse pour
pouvoir être
cycliste de kering au japon il faut
savoir monter son vélo d'une certaine
manière il faut poser la main à un
endroit bien précis que c'était mais non
c'est très très très réglo réglementée
ils ont d'abord des cours en écoles qui
sont accélérées par rapport à un
japonais met donc ils ont énormément de
choses à apprendre et pour une fille qui
a trois ans ne faisait pas de cyclisme
sur piste
c'est un c'est un beau défi de rentrer
dans cette dans cette école du karine
gavand voilà c'est une basketteuse kiki
à des coûts qui a été détectée par part
sur un test sur un test de aller à
l'effort et on a vu qu'elles avaient des
capacités hors normes
ils lui ont fait changer de vélo pour
être sûrs que paul vélo qui avait un
terrain vague
et ça c est ça s'est vérifié elle ne
faisait pas de vélo elle est arrivée à
l'insep on lui a dit voilà tu pourrais
peut-être partir sur un projet pour pour
aller représenter la file à la france
sur sur les olympiades et est
aujourd'hui ben en très peu de temps et
de leur champion les meilleurs
tricolores est devenu champion du monde
juniors elle a eu un pépin cette année
chez les ch et les seigneurs et cpt la
clavicule sur une coupe du monde
donc voilà elle en plein apprentissage
de
de la discipline et aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elle a fait elle a fait le bon choix
hélène halal à 18 ans à les partis au
japon seul on connaît on connaît
l'enseignement des japonais sur guérini
ils sont très très dur est ce que ça
peut pas la dégoûter justement du cycle
66e à une publicité que depuis trois ans
comme les ayant juste en est justement
s'interroger sur son âge dans les
dernières émissions on avait peur
qu'elle manque un peu de maturité et
qu'elle n'est pas vécue à cette chose là
je pense qu'elle y va elle y va de sa
propre initiative sur quelque chose que
voilà pour lequel l animation va
acquérir et de l'expérience et surtout
de la maturité je pense qu'elle va en
plus s'endurcir et s'enrichir et elle va
revenir alors à elle aura tout gagné
et puis on parle pas non plus de comment
dire d'une scène locale oui oui je me
doute bien mais on parle aussi de
quelque chose d'assez court n y va pas
pendant un an deux ans trois ans elle y
va par là pendant plusieurs mois elle
elle prend ce qu'elle a à prendre là bas
est lancée elle prend ses enseignements
et elle revient pour moi elle a tout
gagné a tout gagné georges agostino pour
augusto est question que je me posais
va s'enrichir d'expérience c'est pas
s'enrichir de quelques ça paye aussi le
kerry bon puisque c'est comparer aux
cours et pique etc
il ya des paris dessus les coureurs les
pistards du moins je pense qu'ils
doivent être rémunérés avoir des primes
est ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est pas qu'on soit quand il
y aille pour l'argent c'est l'argent
il va surtout pour pour s'entraîner pour
s'améliorer cela n'empêche pas l'autre
aujourd'hui mathilde les golfeurs matic
d'aujourd'hui c'est trouve que c'est une
c'est une gamine intelligente qui qui
sait servir des réseaux sociaux qui
communiquent et donc elle n'a pas de
problème pour trouver des partenaires
des pros partenaires individuel donc ça
c'est une première chose est vraiment je
pense que dans l'encadrement et d'enfin
d'encadrement proche des structures
familiales
il ya vraiment des gens qui qui la
conseillent qui la conseille bien après
c'est peut-être les déconseille niveau
de l'équipe de france mais c'est vrai
que je pense que là elle et c'est une
c'est une gamine qui a vraiment la tête
sur les épaules et qui est bien qui
vient bien encadré bien accompagné donc
si elle le fait c'est que ça a été
vraiment réfléchi en amont et ça se
passera ça se passera bien pour l genre
de remise vous êtes aussi confiants que
notre ami aliens dujarrier lui qui
connaît
le cyclisme je connais pas le dossier
connaît ce dossier mais bon je pense
déjà à l'esc on se confronter aux autres
déjà c'est c'est une bonne décision est
bon ça prouve que dans sa tête elle est
bien c'est ce qu'elle veut maintenant
sur le plan culturel bon c'est un
changement elle va prendre ce qui est
bon à peu prendre ce qui est bon pour
elle ce qui lui correspond à sa
personnalité et dans d'autres sports il
y en a qui se sont cramés aller à
l'étranger
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est pas
c'est notamment dans le monde du
football
oui mais si je sais pas quelque chose de
discipline individuelle donc le là on
parle d'une personne qui est un projet
qui est un projet qui va dans une dans
un autre pays qui a ou là où
l'enseignement est différent dans même
dans d'autres disciplines
à l'époque les gens ne le faisait dans
les sports de combat là elle a décidé
c'est le quincy ça m'intéresse et
qu'elle veut progresser dans ce domaine
là très rapide dont elle se dit en
allant là bas je vais faire c'est un
stage c'est ça un stage il est dur une
période et c'est précis elle y va pour
prendre ce qu'elle à prendre et revenir
et s'enrichir et sel doit y retourner va
y retourner et maintenant elle va
pouvoir s'évaluer arrivé ici travailler
avec son staff et avec son encadrement
et puis moi je pense que toute façon
aucune expérience
même les joueurs des personnes qui vont
à l'étranger qui ce crabe sur les dix
ans il ce crash mais le gros problème
pro gros problème c'est que parce qu ils
sont partis à l'étranger
ils reviennent on se dit non non on les
craint nous ici on les aide pas et
justement on voit le vin dans un autre
sport
kélonia le football on vague voilà donc
je prends très rapidement il faut savoir
que mathilde et au japon en ce moment on
est aussi sur une période où les
pistards font beaucoup de foncier on
n'est pas sur un travail itt rue ultra
spécifique puisque les prochaines
échéances qui sont championnat de france
où mathilde domine largement
pour elle c'est passé si ya pas de
problème c'est plus à partir du moi je
plaide d'europe qui auront lieu en
novembre je crois pas aux revanches le
peuple devant voilà donc on est quand
même très loin de ces échéances et le
travail qu'elle fait en ce moment là bas
n'est pas du tout antinomiques par
rapport à la suite de la saison
je suis obligé de vous couper la
dernière fois que chez big n
d'accord lui souhaite bon courage à
cette masse et de gros on passe
maintenant notre rubrique des bas dans
cette page débats nous avons parlé de
sorcellerie je sais le sujet vous fait
déjà sourire georges agostino il y a
quelques semaines nina la seule chance a
reconnu officiellement en ile de france
est venu présenter sa discipline à l'ugc
de saint quentin en yvelines dans le
cadre d'une conférence au programme
spiritisme et recette magique
nous en avons profité pour lui demander
c'est le conseiller des sportifs et bien
oui à le travail avec des athlètes de la
région
elle nous explique comment la magie
blanche peut fonctionner sur les
sportifs
écoutez c'est déjà utilisé dans le sport
ce jeudi jour moitié des sportifs qui
font appel à moi pour améliorer leur
leur condition physique ou voir même
pour essayer de faire en sorte qu'on
intervienne sur la réalité pour gagner
ou non fait appel à des identités à des
choses qui font partie d'autres mondes
et
on leur donne quelque chose il nous
donne en retour ce qu'on veut après faut
être initié pour pouvoir arriver à
toucher ce monde là
et puis après ils nous exauce entre
guillemets elle n'a évidemment pas voulu
nous révéler les noms des sportifs avec
lesquels elle travaille la question sur
ce thème la sorcellerie peut-elle
vraiment aider à les sportifs oui ou non
oui pour yann du jard y ait enfin un
petit duel entre vous changez n'y
gagnent george george agostino vous
comment ça non
et dire non non non même si j'espère que
la pâte est conseillé de hatem ben arfa
dont sa carrière au psg
j'espère par celui qui va sortir ce ne
serait pas parce que on sort plein de
trucs sur le pauvre enfin bref n'en sais
je demande on va dire parallèle
parallèle si la sorcellerie et chose à
voir dans le sport waouh ça fait j'ai
pas d'arguments important d'en parler je
l'attends il ya plein de choses qui ont
à voir dans la performance
la médecine l'entraînement j'ai enfin
bref la sorcellerie non c'est parce
qu'on va piquer une poupée parce que je
vois là sa série comme ça qu'on va être
champion du monde
gagner un match où le père de celle ci
existe beaucoup en afrique
je pense qu'il faut y croire les
marabouts existe le str new le sel dans
le sel dans les buts
voilà donc ce n'était pas le bon celle
où je sais pas vous mais non franchement
je ne crois pas du tout nouveau et je
dirais heureusement ce que là il y
aurait chez qui aurait aller chercher
les sorciers tout le monde et n'auront
peut-être passé sur terre superstition
ou à la superstition
monsieur partition dans le sport par
contre ça existe là c'est officieux mais
on est loin de là sur cédric pur et dur
c'est elle que j'imaginais un petit
petit bonhomme et petites pattes de
poulet lancé dans les colonnes de but
voilà non je ne crois pas vous pouvez
poser les questions suivantes et michael
alors la question exactement là ça c'est
vrai peut-elle vraiment aider les
sportifs répondu j'ai répondu oui mais
en fait alors je vais première je n'y
crois pas mais vous à la question oui la
question et peut-elle aider les sportifs
moi je réponds oui tout simplement parce
que dans un sportif c'est un être humain
et les deux éléments qui sont ultra
important c'est la confiance en soi et
le mental est peut-être que rencontrant
la sorcière il va avoir ou en contrat
social et il va prendre confiance en se
disant de toute façon à partir de mots
je les ai rencontrés elle est bien plus
rien ne peut m'arriver et là maintenant
je suis devenu une plus forte et donc du
coup du coup c'est ça va augmenter sa
son capital confiance ça va débloquer
peut-être sertissage certaines choses
chez lui et à partir de là il va
il vas y vas y va c'est très vague de
surmonter ses capacités faut pas oublier
que dans le cyclisme on parle beaucoup
de dopage est derrière abou de
sorcellerie non dernièrement on a parlé
de dopage mentale des manipulations au
niveau du cerveau pour pouvoir augmenter
les performances des athlètes
alors et donc je pense que ce type
d'intervention peut aussi se 500 s'en
rapprocher c'est l'hypnose ça y
ressemble je sais pas si je suis on sait
pas ce qu'elle fait elle ne l'a pas dit
elle est simplement dit qu'elle pouvait
consulter quelqu'un connait sportif la
consulter on sait pas ce qu'elle sait
quelle magie blanche
mais même pour moins visibles en
imaginant je sais même pas ce que c'est
donc
donc pour moi c'est propose des pierres
notamment mais voilà mes de la magie
pourquoi pas je veux dire à partir du
moment où la personne que vous avez en
face et réceptive
ça peut créer des dvd des années fait
passer donc j'allais le dire voilà des
doses des médicaments classés beau chez
des enfants
c'est ça le caleçon fétiche en fait
qu'on met en avant une audition vous
êtes en train de dire eh ben moi alors
en vélo j'ai plus de 4 franchisés plus
qu'à son fétiche parce que tu n'as rien
jeu on a rien sous le cuissard
mais quand je faisais du horla je
portais ça fait deux j'avais deux cas le
sens que je portais toujours quand je
faisais mes compétitions drôle a en
effet un prochain devient pour le
dimanche
et voilà très bientôt le savoir
on écoute et ça je le fais partie de ces
règles sont par rapport à savoir qu'il
arrive son nom mais je pense que en
effet c'est le sportif qui va danser
dans ces moyens-là se dit que quelque
part il fait tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir pour pouvoir performer être
mieux se sentir au mieux y arriver il
croire avoir confiance y croire vraiment
et on peut pas je pense que ça rien de
répréhensibles ni rien après faudrait
voir vraiment ce qu'elle fait mais c'est
le même c'est le drôle qu'un coach qu'un
coach en développement personnel est la
mission d'accord on voit toujours en fin
de compte quand j'entends parler où je
dis quelque chose sur la sorcellerie
c'est pas mon quotidien je vois toujours
dans le côté négatif c'est pas pour
aider quelqu'un plus performant plus
grand plus fort plus beau c'est toujours
au détriment ils vont marquer un but ils
vont faire ils vont se casser la jambe
ils vont se blesser au niveau de
l'adversaire tu dois toujours le côté
négatif et non pas le jeu je te donne
une pierre parce que cette pierre là et
là elle a ses effets la saison est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle m'a dit qu'elle
va dégager va t'aider à à compenser un
manque que tu peux avoir
je vais vous parler des pierres dendre
qu'on peut donner pour les enfants pour
éviter le mal de dents et ben ya
certains enfants chez qui c'est qui ça
fonctionne et d'autres chez qui ça
fonctionne pas donc oui peut-être qu'il
ya des petits pouvoirs qui peuvent être
aidés et du coup on donne de la
confiance aux à l'athlète est alors
après je le côté culturel à côté un côté
culturel et un côté et un côté croyances
et en cause les supérieurs tout à
l'heure aucune équipe africaine à gagner
une coupe d'angola au marabout mais par
contre les rumeurs disent que les
sénégalais en 2002 lors de la coupe du
monde avait été voir des marabouts pour
gagner contre l'équipe de france et ils
ont gagné contre l'équipe de france et
regagner ils ont gagné mais ils ont
parlé
si si ils ont pas gagné tous les après
ski comme je vous dis c'est
psychologique inconscient chaque fois
que les gens leur croyance voilà moi je
moi je crois en dieu ces prophètes
voilà maintenant elle est comment
prophète à la caisse
voilà donc après les croyances les
superstitions les sas et ses propres à
la personne je veux dire comme il dit
lui il ya des joueurs de foot pareil
delio onnis le grand buteur argentin de
l'époque et changeait pas de slip temps
qui marquait heureusement heureusement
qu'il est là mais quoi heureusement
qu'ils le quilleuc il l'avait bon après
c'est respectable attention il faut pas
du moment que les personnes comment on
dit sur le plan humain humains et et
comment psychologique ça le il se trouve
que ça l'ofs
ça leur permet de performer qu'ils
aillent performer dans ce sens là
maintenant il y en a d'autres qui
performent il y en a d'autres qui
performent sans ça mais ce terme
chancellerie qui veut annoncer un coach
psychologique coach quelque chose je
sais pourquoi tu es sorcière
essentiellement connue en ile-de-france
la caution des amulettes des choses
comme ça laval afin notamment d' accord
ces gens sont intéressés
ça nous sort la potion magique d'obélix
écoutez l'oréal assure cédric avoir vu
noël ils ont reçu et est-ce qu'il faut
que les sportifs se laisse peut-être
influencé par les marabouts il ya
notamment cette histoire de romelu
lukaku le joueur qui était à l'époque à
chelsea et à l'époque à everton et qui a
été voir un marabout qui lui a conseillé
d'aller à chelsea
est ce que vous comprenez ça georges
gomis est ce qu'il faut c'est un
français qui croient presse et des
croyances on est on est dans le dans le
fin fond de la bretagne ou dans le fin
fond de certains et à certaines
croyances et les croyances des 6 et
culturel cc66 ici comment si lui il a
décidé de faire cette démarche là et que
derrière ça si ça a été bénéfique pour
les mains si demain si demain et de
faire un choix peut-être qu'il irait
encore voir cette personne pour lui dire
bah écoute c'est qu'au pensez vous de ce
choix là et ces deux personnes là bas ça
sera et parce qu'il y à trouver il y a
trouvé son sont bien maintenant moi
personnellement si j'ai un conseil à
donner à quelqu'un je préfère aller
demander je vais j'ai demandé à mon
entourage je promets qu'ils s'entraînent
plus tôt que plus qu'il aille voir mais
voilà c'est incompatible voilà c'est
l'entraînement c'est la base mais voilà
le maroc
abriel croyances hier le coach peut
avoir un mot un petit truc qui va faire
que mais c'est la sportive qui doit
faire la démarche l'histoire de
discernement
si en fonction des personnes qu'on va
voir c'est sûr que si on prend le petit
papier qu'on a dans sa boîte aux lettres
c'est pas la même chose que recommandé
par quelqu'un qui voit là qui a déjà
peut-être une expérience avec ça voilà
si je pense que si on a le bon
discernement et qu'on s'entraîne bien en
parallèle et qu'on fait ce qu'il faut
mais sur tous les plans pour réussir
c'est qu'un plus et voilà c'est qu'une
pierre en plus à l'édifice je pense que
son destin et on veut enfin quand même
au destin malgré on voit on voit des
gens qui qui dit comment qui qui ont des
blessures qui reviennent des gens qui
passent par dés d'autres d'autres
chemins et qui arrivent à leurs
objectifs
bon ben c'est et on a vu qu'on est avec
un destin et je pense pas qu'on puisse
le modifier de manière peu importe la
manière seul le résultat compte là je
terminerai sur ces matériels à dessus
est ce que ça pourrait être considéré
comme de la trilogie comme du dopage ne
pas être en tout temps qui trompe pas
dans la potion magique oui si la potion
magique ou si on leur fait avaler ce
cher sportif qui croit à quelque produit
miracle oui sa pointure oui je peux
enfin je pense parce que les cuisses de
poulet ça marche pas donc s'y mettre des
produits dedans qui sont reconnues
depuis effectivement si ça reste au
niveau spirituel ou à bout de celle sur
la seule de vélo pour 5 puis 8
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent le jeudi 1 31 mai pour une
nouvelle émission en direct du lieu-dit
national de saint quentin en yvelines
on va terminer par une citation du king
eric cantona vous pouvez changer de
femme d'opinion politique de religion
mais vous ne pouvez jamais changé à des
clips de foot préférée je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78 ans au plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]